après cinq heures de voyage il pose
enfin leurs valises dans ce gîte du haut
doubs ces collégiens du val d'oise vont
s'installer pour une semaine et poser
vos sacs les filles 1 le temps qu'on
fasse un point d'accueil et si vous êtes
au troisième et elles n'ont pas fini de
se dépenser
chacune choisit sa chambre à peine le
temps de prendre ses quartiers
il faut déjà se préparer pour les
activités cette semaine le gîte
accueille trois groupes
plus de 170 enfants répartis sur deux
bâtiments
le hasard fait qu'on l'a effectivement
trois groupes différents des environs de
paris
sinon on avait un monde parce qu'en
france la plus juste ici à chaque fois
il faut recharger
c'est après midi pour se mettre en
jambes
en l'état les lycéens s'essaye au
biathlon de sa venue et offre à chaque
fois tu charges
pas facile de trouver ses marques visez
stabilité les novices de la gâchette
doivent se concentrer
on est du couac avec les potes c'est
écrit dessus sans ballon j'aime bien
j'aime bien tirer du coup sûr un des
sites comme ça c'est sympa est moniteur
espace pont d'or c'est être
polyvalent c'est à dire qu on est aussi
bien amenée à pouvoir conduire un bus
faire du bio pions faire du ski de fond
faire du ski alpin sur les activités et
faire de la raquette et l'été printemps
été automne on est sur des activités
estivales nautique a pas de routine
comme la plupart des saisonniers
guillaume travaille dix mois sur douze
pour le même employeur l'association
espace mont d'or emploie 50 permanent et
jusqu'à 200 salariés en pleine saison
hébergeur transporteurs accompagnateurs
c'est le plus gros opérateur touristique
du haut doubs les cm1 dans la preuve de
droits de l'histoire a commencé il ya 40
ans au départ avec un centre de ski de
fond c'est ce positionnement là et cette
offre là qui nous distingue d'offres
d'autres offres concurrentielles sur ce
territoire et qui je dirais nous enfin
permet une certaine une certaine
performance économique
ils sont quinze points de croissance sur
l'hiver et puis peut-être autour de 15 à
20 points sur le printemps grâce à ses
activités quatre saisons et son
organisme de formation la structure a su
se développer et insuffler le goût de la
nature et de laventure au plus grand
nombre